qui m'amène quintet de nombreux français
nous les mutuelles maladie montel moins
remboursés car monaco depuis un décret
paru hier au journal officiel
on demande de l'adhérent ces mutuelles
de payer 5 à 12% des frais de maîtrise
ou de pharmacie
sauf pour les dépenses hospitalières at
il assurés sociaux qui sont souvent des
mutualistes se voir remis un peu de leur
avantage
bref sorelois sans équivoque de la
fédération nationale de la mutualité
c'est la première fois que l'on porte
atteinte à des principes fondamentaux du
mouvement mutualiste la liberté d'action
de soi même et sa protection sociale
contre les aléas de la vie est de nature
à réduire les dépenses de sécurité
sociale
nous ne le pensons absolument pas pour
son sérieux dans ce rapport les sketches
en général des affaires sociales même à
prouver que les mutualistes n'était pas
consommateur disons de chantier
davantage même quelques mois les mythes
la liste parce qu'ils sont très
conscients ses dépenses de santé étant
donné qu'il ya des pays où elles sont
moins consommateurs mais comment en êtes
vous de réagir à l'application ce décret
la fédération nationale de la mutualité
française mais on citera pas si société
de base appliquez ce t il est bien
entendu que ce sont les sociétés qui
décident elles mêmes la fédération
nationale sera pas parce qu'elle dit non
à ceux des traits particuliers tout voir
le plus souvent possible et revendique
c'est un sou pour cent de la frais
médicaux ou juillet où les chefs de
famille
volontairement à une société nucléaire
celle ci grâce à une convention passée
avec la sécurité sociale l'a renversée
banques les 25 à 30% nous ramons stable
au titre des prestations obligatoires
il est enfant les sociétés ou
groupements mutualistes
elle emploie 48 personnes société non
lucratif elle le perd donc faire de
bénéfices et leurs excédents de recettes
doit servir par exemple à réduire les
cotisations d'une année sur l'autre
le total des recettes mutualiste était
de 1 milliard de francs en 1979 4 3
millions de français en sont les
bénéficiaires